so what's the difference in
uh the arm folks and intel in terms of
the way they're approaching this problem
well intel almost all their processor
designs were
you know very custom high-end you know
for the last 15-20 years
the fastest horse possible yeah in one
horsepower
yeah and then architecture they're
really good but the company itself was
fairly insular to what's going on in the
industry with cad tools and stuff and
there's this debate about custom design
versus synthesis
and how do you approach that i'd say
intel was slow on the
cutting to synthesize processors arm
came in from the bottom and they
generated ip which went to all kinds of
customers
so they had very little say how the
customer implemented their
ip so arm is super friendly to the
synthesis ip environment whereas intel
said we're going to make this great
client chip server chip with our own cad
tools with our own process with our own
you know other supporting ip and
everything only works with our stuff
so is that is arm winning the mobile
platform space in terms of processors
and so
in that what you're describing is why
they're winning
well they had lots of people doing lots
of different experiments
so they controlled the processor
architecture and ip
but they let people put in lots of
different chips and there was a lot of
variability in what happened there
whereas intel when they made their
mobile their foray into mobile they had
one team doing one
part right so it wasn't 10 experiments
and then their mindset was pc mindset
microsoft software mindset and that
brought a whole bunch of things along
that
the mobile world embedded world don't do
do you think it was possible for intel
to pivot hard and win the mobile
market
you